In this video, we will see how to debug an error
you encounter when running trainer.train().
As an example, we will use this script that
finetunes a bert model on the GLUE MNLI dataset.
Checkout the videos linked below to
see how we came to such a script,
here we want to learn how to debug the problems
in it. Running the script gives us an error pretty
fast. It happens at the line where we feed the
inputs to the model, according to the traceback.
That tells us there is a problem there, but the
problem could come from many different causes.
To debug an error in a training, you need to
make sure each step of the training pipeline
works as intended. This means checking that
the inputs of your dataset are correct,
you can batch them together, feed
them through the model to get a loss,
then compute the gradients of that loss
before performing an optimizer step.
So let's start by looking at the training dataset
this Trainer is using. There is definitely a
problem there as we see texts and not numbers. The
error message was telling us the model did not get
input IDs and we do not have those in the dataset
indeed. Looking back at our code, we can see we
made a mistake and passed the wrong datasets to
the Trainer. So let's fix that and run again.
Now we have a new error. Inspecting the traceback
tells us it happens when we try to create a batch,
specifically to group the features in a tensor.
We can confirm this by asking the Trainer to get
us a batch of the training data loader, which
reproduces the same error. Either by inspecting
the inputs or debugging, we can then see they are
not all of the same size. This is because we have
not passed a data collator to do the padding in
the Trainer and didn't pad when preprocessing
the data either. Padding inside the Trainer is
normally the default, but only if you provide
your tokenizer to the Trainer, and we forgot to
do that. So let's fix the issue and run again.
This time we get a nasty CUDA error. They
are very difficult to debug because for one,
they put your kernel in a state that is not
recoverable (so you have to restart your
notebook from the beginning) and two, the
traceback is completely useless for those.
Here the traceback tells us the error happens when
we do the gradient computation with loss.backward,
but as we will see later on that is not the
case. This is because everything that happens
on the GPU is done asynchronously: when you
execute the model call, what the program does
is just stacking that in the queue of GPU, then
(if the GPU didn't have any current job to do),
the work will start on the GPU at the same time
as the CPU will move to the next instruction.
Continuing with the extraction of the loss, this
is stacked into the GPU queue while the CPU moves
to the instruction loss.backward. But the GPU
still hasn't finished the forward pass of the
model since all that took no time at all. The CPU
stops moving forward, because loss.backward as an
instruction telling it to wait for the GPUs to be
finished, and when the GPU encounters an error,
it gives with a cryptic message back to the
CPU, who raises the error at the wrong place.
So to debug this, we will need to execute the
next steps of the training pipeline on the CPU.
It is very easy to do, and we get a traceback
we can trust this time. As we said before,
the error happens during the forward pass
of the model, and it's an index error.
With a bit of debugging, we see we have labels
ranging from 0 to 2, so three different values,
but our outputs have a shape of batch size per 2.
It looks like our model has the wrong number of
labels! We can indeed confirm that, and now that
we know it's easy to fix it in the code by adding
num_labels=3 when we create the model. Now the
training script will run to completion! We did not
need it yet, but here is how we would debug the
next step of the pipeline, gradient computation,
as well as the optimizer step. With all of
this, good luck debugging your own trainings!